au cours des derniers mois des millions
de personnes ont été séduites par les
thèses conspirationnistes du mouvement
donne une grosse portion d'entre eux ont
suivi à la lettre le message du
mystérieux ku qui leur demandait en
somme de faire confiance au plan trust
de preuves rattrapé par la réalité
le choc a donc été brutal pour plusieurs
adeptes en voyant donald trump perdre
l'élection éventuellement céder les
rênes du pouvoir à joe biden
j'ai perdu ma femme pour ku et nous
abandonner quand nous en avions le plus
besoin
q- nous as tu abandonné on a tout donné
et aucun résultat on a alors écrit
certains d'entre eux sur le forum est
cool malgré tout d'autres adeptes
persiste et s'accroche encore contre
vents et marées qu'arrive-t-il lorsque
votre système de croyances ses formes
tristan mendès france bonjour bonjour
d'aprés ce que vous observez le comment
les adeptes de cloyne s'ajuste à la
réalité du changement de garde à
washington pour les purs et durs
leurs profils sont plutôt à s'inquiétant
le train de la réalité ces affronts a
explosé face au réel avec l'élection de
valve a misé l'inauguration de baden et
donc ceux qui restent sont vraiment les
plus radicaux et c des personnes ou des
profils qui risque de basculer dans
quelque chose d'encore plus radicale et
à travers tout ça bail à celui qui a été
vu comme le prophète ou l'oracle le
mystérieux ku qui s'est fait faut bien
dire assez discret depuis la mi décembre
qu'adviendra-t-il de ce vecteur
important de la pensée
conspirationnistes de cloyne à nouveau
ce qui est assez fascinant avec cette
mouvance cannon c'est que elle elle peut
et elle va survivre
akio elle n'a plus besoin de cul le
mouvement ku c'est moins quelque chose
de bien établi qu'un état d'esprit face
au réel et l'idée c'est de lire toute
l'actualité avec des lunettes biaisée
des lunettes complotistes ça intègre en
gros une lecture de l'actualité une
lecture complète toi et pendant la
pandémie konan a gagné beaucoup
d'adeptes au sein de groupes qui n'était
pas nécessairement acquis à sa cause des
adeptes de médecine naturelle de yoga de
spiritualité est-ce que qui ordonne peut
encore conquérir des adeptes dans
d'autres sphères en ce moment je pense
que les deux mouvements
il ya à la fois ce coeur nucléaire qui
va rester qui va se radicaliser et qui
est effectivement un lait que danone pur
et dur et il ya cette contamination du
discours qu 'on dans les autres sphères
les sphères du bien-être l'espère de la
spiritualité en ligne qui aurait ont été
contaminés par des éléments du discours
et cette contamination va perdurer
c'est ça qui est assez déroutant avec
cette mouvance c'est que c'est un
process plus que un corpus identifié
qu'une que qu'un lot de discours très
spécifique le complot de l'élite
mondiale existait avant que tu as 'non'
a été accélérée par tuân anh tuân anh a
contaminé d'autres communautés avec ses
discours en leur donnant des éléments
éventuellement pour asseoir leurs
fantasmes de montclos des élites
mondiales et c'est quelque part un virus
qui a été disséminé par cette mouvance
cuenot et un termine un veau moi et tous
ceux qui analysent et observent cette
mouvance devront s'ajuster alors que le
contexte n'a it ain t elle changer
radicalement suivre ce mouvement ça va
être un peu plus compliqué
vraisemblablement ils vont s'enferrer
plus profondément dans sur le web ou sur
les différentes plateformes
et puis il ya encore une fois mais là il
faudra un peu de temps pour voir si ce
mouvement qu 'on va se dissoudre dans
d'autres mouvances parce qu'il ce qu'il
ne faut pas oublier c'est que les
millions d'adeptes de q&a note même s'il
y en a une partie peut-être
significative qui quittent le bateau
cannon c'est des gens qui ont sont
toujours
susceptible d'être sensible au discours
complotistes en général donc s'ils
quittent le bateau mère tu hanon
ils ne vont pas quitter l'univers
complotistes c'est des gens qui ont un
besoin et qu'ils vont continuer
vraisemblablement simplement à aller
dans d'autres espaces et poursuivre leur
cheminement existentiel complotistes